that was made
by many of the polytheist
civilizations. Most pagan
rights and pagan civilizations
have ascribed to the omnipotent
creator a child or children.
And this idea of merging the
divine and the created, the
creator and the creation,
merging them into one, is not a
new idea. It's not a new
concept. This is a concept that
has been peddled for millennia
by a Shaitan and his and his
followers. This is not a new
concept and it's interesting
sometimes to listen to this
kind of rhetoric come from
those who allegedly follow Isa
Alaihi Salam allegedly follow
Ibrahim follow Musa that they
would, that they would say
this. and sometimes it's
interesting to watch how
enthusiastic they get about
this concept as if this is this
is a concept which is new and
only Christianity believes
this. This is not new. This is
older than the hills. Every
pagan civilization of
noteworthiness has come up with
this idea. This is not new. And
the idea of a sacrificial lamb
and the idea of a son and the
idea of a savior that will take
on the sins of mankind. This is
not new. This dates back as far
as history dates back.
Literally
as far
as we have documented
history, we have these ideas
that were documented all the
way back to the ancient
Egyptians and the pyramids all
the way back to ancient Persia
and ancient Rome. This idea of
merging the creator and the
creation, the divine, and the
mortal and having this kind of
hybrid of divinity and
mortality in one. This is not a
new concept and this is not
particular to Christianity. It
is actually very very very,
very,
it's it's actually very mundane
and very normal. It's the
normal step to take in human
thought when a person begins to
worship other than Allah. This
will follow naturally. It's the
next logical step.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in the Quran to the prophet
that which translates to say to
them if Allah did, in fact,
have a son, I would be the
first to worship him. That's
the next logical step. Next
logical step, if such a thing
were to be, then, yes, we
would, we would worship. But
this is, this is an impossible
and so, this is not unique to
Christianity. This is not
unique to everyone has claimed
this claim. If we look to the
story of Horus and ancient
Egyptian time, we look to the
story of Mythra in Persian.
Mythra of Persia, actually was
crucified, was buried in a
tomb, he had twelve disciples.
I'm talking about Mythra. I'm
not talking about Jesus of
Nazareth. I'm talking about
Mythra. He was buried in a
tomb. He was resurrected on the
third day. His followers had to
eat part of his flesh as as a
ritual Exact same story that
they claim occurred with Asa
Alaihi Salam. The exact same
story. As a matter of fact, if
you remove the names and switch
them around, they are
interchangeable. Mythra and
Jesus, as they say, as it
claimed and so this is not a
unique concept This is not new.
This concept is as old as the
hills. What is unique is
monotheism, the worship of
Allah without any partners. It
seems unique because of the
sheer amount of polytheism that
has leaked its way into the
human heart and mind. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says and
they claim that Al Rahman has
taken for himself children.
Subhanahu far above is he from
all of this. Rather, these
angels that they refer to as
the children of Allah or the
daughters of Allah more
specifically. They are merely
honored servants of Allah. They
do not precede him with any
statement and with by command,
they act What does this mean?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
is praising them. He's praising
the angels. He's praising their
obedience, right? He is
praising the obedience of the
angels.
This articulates that's the
angels have the ability to
disobey Allah but they do not.
Hence, the praise. This is a
mistaken concept that is kind
of spread
amongst many Muslims, a a
actually a startling number of
Muslims is that the angels do
not have the ability to disobey
Allah. This is not correct.
This is nowhere in the Quran,
nowhere in the Sunnah. and if
that were the case, then, there
would be no need to praise
them. There would be no meaning
to this praise. Allah is
praising them for their
dutifulness that they're always
doing what Allah tells them.
How would that be praiseworthy
if they didn't have the ability
to disobey him? Would that be
praise or would that be
mockery? Imagine this with me.
Imagine there is a person who
is mute.
and speak
and then we say, you
know, he is so soft spoken.
He's very stoic. Doesn't speak
at all. Is this praise or is
this mockery? someone who can't
move on his own. Someone
paralyzed. Say, you know, he's
a real home buddy. He doesn't
go out at all Is this praise or
mockery? It's mockery. So it is
impossible for this to be the
case The angels have the
ability to disobey Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala but they do
not. That is where the praise
comes from. You only praise a
person for being stoic and
being a man of few words if
they can speak but choose not
to. That's the only time it
becomes praise. Likewise, the
only way that the angels can be
praised for their dutifulness
is if they have the ability to
disobey Allah but they do not.
They don't disobey Allah. and
I've seen this even written in
books even in books written.
and this is originally taken
from the words of a very
ancient group of innovators
that were around in the time of
the companions latter
generations of the companions
known as the Jibreel. They
believe that we do not have any
free will. We are forced by
destiny. We don't have any
choice. Our choices have been
predetermined for us. And we
have no ability to make our own
choice. This group of people
came up with this and this is
originally taken from the
philosophies of Greek Roman
mythology
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
continues to praise the angels
saying he knows what is before
them and what is behind them.
What they have done and what
they will do. What their future
holds and what their past
holds. And they do not they do
not intercede on behalf of
anyone except for those whom
Allah is pleased with them to
intercede. And they are in
constant exalted fear of Allah.
Notice here how Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala affirms that the
angels will be interceding on
behalf of individuals. As a
matter of fact, the angels are
interceding right now. On
behalf of of the believers.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions in those are those who
are carrying the throne of
Allah and those who are close
to the throne of Allah. They
are constantly making dua for
the believers on the earth.
This is a type of intercession
An intersession will be on the
day of resurrection. For the
angels and for the prophets and
for the martyrs and for the
righteous. But how do we
understand this verse and other
verses in the Quran which
articulate that there will be
no intercession on the day of
resurrection.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
He described the day of
resurrection as being a day
when there will be No.
trade, commerce, and buy your
way out of something. There
will be no relations
[Silence]
graves or worship landmarks or
whatever it is they worshiped
and they claimed that these
spirits, these souls, these
righteous people would
intercede on their behalf. So,
if they worship these things
other than Allah, these things
had an unremitted intercession
with Allah that they held, that
they would force their
intercession on Allah. Just as
a king's court, will force its
intercession on the king's
decisions. This was their
concept and so where we find in
the Quran that Allah says,
there is no intersession. He's
speaking about what? That
intercession, that concept of
intercession. Where Allah
documents for us their belief
system and says, they worship
other than Allah and they say,
They worship other than Allah
and say, these things that we
worship aside from Allah are
our interceders with Allah.
That intercession does not
exist. The intercession that
does exist is the intercession
that Allah affirms.
intercession of the angels,
intercessions of the prophets,
intercession of the prophet
Muhammad intercession of this
intercession is, is affirmed
but what kind of intercession
is this? This is a conditional
intercession. that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala allows the
intersession that he is
generally pleased with the
person whom they are
interceding on behalf of and is
pleased with the one who is
interceding. Those are the
conditions of intersession and
as for the statement of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in Surat in
Allah says
who is he that will come and
force his intercession upon
Allah? Who is he that will
intercede before Allah without
his permission. This is a
rhetorical question. We can
replace it with the negative
and say, none will intercede
before Allah except by his
permission. That's what the
verse means. intersession
exists but it does not exist in
the way that they believed.
That intercession is negated in
the Quran. We've gone a little
over time tonight. that is
because many important topics
had come up
[Arabic recitation]